2021 une année record pour la
rémunération des patrons des entreprises
françaises ceux du CAC 40 ont reçu 7,9
millions d'euros en moyenne un bon
historique de 52% par rapport à 2019
avant la crise portée par des
performances exceptionnelles de la
reprise après covid dans ce centre de
distribution les 35 bénévoles ont repris
du service pour une nouvelle campagne
d'hiver produit frais boîte de conserve
cela fait 21 ans que Nicole bénéficie de
l'aide alimentaire des restos essentiels
pour cette allocataire du RSA enfin les
restos ben je ne mangerai pas parce
qu'une fois que j'ai payé tout le même
facteurs me reste entre 20 et 30 euros
pour vide le patron du gros automobile
stellantis Carlos Tavares et ses 66,7
millions d'euros
un chiffre contesté par la société
en deuxième position le patron de
Dassault Systèmes plus de 44 millions
d'euros l'an passé
dernier sur le podium le PDG de
Téléperformance numéro 1 mondial des
plateformes d'appel
19,6 millions d'euros 250 familles sont
en scrides dans ce centre de Tourcoing
et elle devrait être plus nombreuses ces
prochaines semaines avec l'inflation et
l'augmentation des coûts de l'énergie
beaucoup à vous ne plus y arriver pour
que les familles n'aient pas à choisir
entre se nourrir ou se chauffer
désormais les Restos du Coeur tiennent
compte dans leur critères des dépenses
énergétiques et on a fait une décision
symbolique pour la sobriété énergétique
regardez notre écran est noir ce matin
alors en fait c'est pas du tout la
sécurité énergétique c'est juste qu'il a
grillé
Cruella Rousseau on s'en fout on s'en
fout pas Mehdi pour une fois qu'il dit
pas une connerie franchement on s'en
fout pas
Jérôme
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec toi
aussi elle est flippante c'est toi un
grand garçon comme ça
ou je sais pas ce qu'elle voit mais elle
est flippante si vous réalisez que 80%
de la surface de la Terre est occupé par
le bétail et que jusqu'en 2050 la
demande pour la viande va augmenter de
70%
on comprend que c'est impossible et
qu'il faut une alternative pour les
protéines Charles
les insectes permettrait de nourrir 10
milliards d'êtres humains à l'horizon
2050 moi pour moi c'est une Queen j'aime
bien les gens marginaux un peu fou donc
elle sort du lot c'est une Queen
c'est pas que je l'aime bien je la
trouve complètement mais elle sort du
lot elle sort même du PAF elle de la
politique c'est une Queen du buzz et
elle me distrait je la remercie pour son
compte Twitter je la remercie chaque
jour au quotidien depuis Kelon musk a
repris Twitter beaucoup d'utilisateurs
veulent fuir la plateforme mais pas
simple de lui trouver un remplaçant
d'abord il y a eu la ruée vers Mastodon
avec plus de 2 millions d'utilisateurs
par mois un succès mais la plateforme
semble trop compliquée pour être
populaire chaque jour un réseau social
est présenté comme l'eldorado cohost
poste
IVe et bientôt blue sky la future
plateforme du fondateur de Twitter Jack
Dorsey pendant ce temps Elon Musk jubile
Twitter abattu son record d'activité la
semaine dernière
ensuite le Z synonyme de chelou aussi en
verlan aux Arbus oui aux États-Unis un
tradition oblige et Thanksgiving
approchant je Biden a accordé devant un
parquet un parterre des colliers la
grâce présidentielle à deux dindes
blanches et oui pépites et chocolat
c'est leur nom ne seront donc pas servis
et farcis c'est le cérémonie est
l'occasion chaque année pour le chef de
la Maison Blanche de souffrir un moment
de détente et de plaisanter aussi sur
son bilan
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi je sens pas du tout la truffe mais
moi je le sens non moi je le sens pas
mal quand même que moi je sens parfois
avec 22 g d'insectes seulement ce menu
dispense déjà 13 g de protéines
l'équivalent de la moitié d'un steak
en intégrant les insectes à des plats
familiers le cuisinier défricheur espère
que les foyers finiront par les adopter
pour moi la truffe je la connaissais en
chocolat mais pas vraiment
en sauce ou dans l'assiette en fait mais
sinon ça va c'était c'était bon
un président des États-Unis qui a
interview des dindes
essayez de suivre Patrick le plus
ridicule de l'agenda du président
américain chaque année
11 sur 20 j'ai bien mangé c'était bon
enfin moi j'aurais préféré ma raclette
là on touche le fond à Christelle on est
en train de comparer du foie gras de la
truffe à une raclette
Joe tu penses qu'est-ce qui va gagner
vous avez déjà tous gagné pour moi je
t'ai dit il y a une seule place
franchement je sais pas parce que non me
montre les fesses déjà si je devais me
fier que au sport tu vois par exemple
bah ça serait pas toi par exemple
siffler et hué pour avoir monté les
marches d'une pyramide de Mexique en
plus de ne pas respecter les consignes
cette touriste espagnol se met à danser
alors qu'un agent lui demande de
descendre au pied du monument l'attente
des dizaines de locaux ou très par son
comportement
certains son prénom physiquement ça ne
me fait pas rire c'est une tragédie
j'ai envie de crier tu as envie de crier
vas-y vas-y
depuis 2008 il est interdit de monter
ses marches pour des raisons de sécurité
et pour préserver le site de
tchétchénida l'une des 7 merveilles du
monde la tourisme fait l'objet de
poursuit elle risque une amende allant
de 5000 à 7500 euros il faut que tu sers
es
[Musique]